just go through some of the facts of the
situation because this is mined
ourselves first of all of what we're
talking about these are the figures for
this year alone forty-six thousand
migrants crossing so far this year
alternately up on the same figure for
the period last year and of those
already we know they have been seventeen
hundred and fifty either missing or dead
so underlying what a serious situation
this is and we saw today the EU asking
you ever support when it came to
military action is that the right kind
of approach it's been controversial we'd
be very concerned about that if it's the
only thing as being suggested we're
concerned about it in it for itself
where there's a great worry that it
exacerbates an already critical
situation in North Africa and pause fuel
on are already raging fire what we need
to do is put the safety of migrants
first and center of any European
response and I think a european
commission of dunno europe a favor by
coming up with this set of proposals
because it goes much further than
military action it does call for it w
latocha vs. wolf we'll look at in a bit
more detail at the proposal in a second
let's just remind ourselves of the
number of asylum applications we've seen
because 626 thousand last year and that
is the highest bigger since 1992 if we
look at it my country is quite an
interesting pattern isn't it because
start by looking here at the UK 32,000
the calm to eurostat compare that with
hungary smaller population but 43
thousand applications 64,000 in france
if we go to Italy 65,000 but take a look
here at Sweden 81,000 and the particular
Germany over 200,000 so not exactly
distributed equally when it comes the
size of the economy or did the popular
no indeed and the UK takes below the
European average if you look at the
number of applications per head of the
population so we have the capacity to do
more in the UK and here's an opportunity
opening up for us to play a full part in
a coordinated European response and
there has been this talk hasn't there in
The Times today or perhaps
redistribution and a quota based on the
income the population
unemployment levels in a country and
that it claims could mean that we're
required to take double the amount of
asylum seekers because relatively
speaking we are a high income and low
unemployment yes that figure is a is a
specious figure to be honest the UK
can't be forced to take any we have
opted out of justice and Home Affairs
legislation in Europe and Europe cannot
compel the UK to take any numbers at all
we hope the UK response will be to
contribute voluntarily to any schemes
being developed and the European
Commission are talking about two schemes
one is relocation of people who are
brought ashore from the votes in the
Mediterranean and how do we support the
frontline States Italy Spain Greece
Malta to better cope with that they're
stretched already but the second
proposal is a much more upstream measure
which is resettlement quotas to bring
people who are at risk directly into the
countries of Europe on a fair allocated
basis and that's the way to tackle the
smuggling not to be dropping off the
reaction of course politically as well
been hearing from Nigel Farage amongst
others as well I don't want us to be
part of a comedy you asylum policy and
even if Mr Cameron attempts to resist
all they have to do in Italy is to give
people EU passports and then all of them
if they wish can come to Britain so I
think Cameron's first euro crisis has
started today